21 einkaufen kein kaufen verbraucher
wurst presley wahrhafter hat aber auch
was wir zu tun sprach hopp komme mache
ihm spaß macht selber berichtet selber
kein anderer lacht einfach minecraft
freunde willkommen zu monday play heute
mit konkav der denn wir spielen montags
meiner ist doch ein kollege den ihr
vielleicht hier und da mal sachen wird
aber aber es wird ja den sieht auch in
der fei scam einfach sind ja genau face
camp läuft okay hallöchen so eine von
crafter du hast ja schon aber monday
play nämlich beim angeblich bei
montagsmaler dabei und kennt der so
insofern das spielprinzip
hier sehen wir natürlich erst mal den
ananas man an dass anderen last lukas
macht die anderen nass ich finde das hat
schon ganz gut getroffen
direkt los es geht direkt los ok ok 32
einfluss auf mein okay so ich bin bereit
ich habe es mir bequem gemacht ich hab
hier total ich habe hier auch vorn ich
hab viel cola
ja ich habe den termin gelte jetzt lange
zwei minuten 3 2 1 los verkaufen
verizon gleisen bis haufen leiser mal
hält einen goldenen apfel ein eiserner
apfel leise ein u boot von einem gipfel
eine birne reisen pilz
apfel ist das eindeutig eisen abfüllten
außerirdischer roboter die glocke seine
eier nachher hin
april war schon nah dran am stiel
ob ein apfel goldener apfel apple ja er
hat uns richtig
da weiß ich doch schön aus ist das schön
gebaut oder hast recht okay ein punkt
geht an den unternehmen ist gut wir
können noch mal seinen eigenen medley
okay leute die waren vor 3310 so ein
fehler machen brille ein fisch schnauze
alter was euch da fisch denken was sagst
du willst wie wählen denn eure stühle
aus eine ist nc stern
du machst du bitte keine marken ich
kenne ich aus
anders kopf nein es ist etwas anderer
stil aus minecraft für eine blume
herbert sollich das wäre nicht clever
wie die heißt gar nicht in unserer stadt
hängt verstehen ich bin für alle autoren
der friedhof nein das ist etwas was wir
alle sehr früh da zu sein ist richtig
guter gegner
ja man werde noch mal hier
wenn du noch mal dabei sein sollte es
bei montagsmaler welche mir vorher alle
deine videos angeschaut und war die
nacht gut oder war die er so
durchwachsen sagen ich habe erst mal
eine halbe stunde morgens ein finne zu
suchen lautet der text den ball direkt
gekommen ist okay aber gamescom
diese sache wird immens schwer für mich
drei verkaufen
ich wusste ich musste es einfach im kopf
nike in der wolke in kampong gebinde ein
kopf die firma ein anderer seine milch
glasflaschen ein viereck auf ein
rechteck malibu erstmal was passt denn
wenn ihr hier denkt man überhaupt nicht
nach die ordner alle begriffe reihen die
man im kopf hat brainstorming pur das
ist so eine blume vergleich vincent ist
klar
ja das sieht aus wie sonne so eine
wasserblase es ist weiblich es geht um
diese sachen die hier drauf würde ich
auch drauf stehe ja war da kommt auch
etwas vor weil das sind so raunt in der
spitze hätten schlachten kribbeln wie
soll denn ich leide darunter hängen
hätten
nein deine titten es sind
ich sage jetzt das wort was davor kommt
wer zuerst dahinter das ganze war ich
sage jetzt das wort was ich war gesagt
jetzt das erste wort von was
fortschritten kommt wer dann das ganze
wort sagt oder ich sage ein synonym für
das erste wort ja wie es bei rosenheim
hat in bonn das hälfte des back in the
game
ich wollte diese runde daheim aber alle
leisten da wo ich auch mal punkt mache
da helfe ich natürlich gerne mit ihr das
schnell alles zu beseitigen jetzt habe
ich meinen lauf jetzt wenn ich richtig
drin hat ein hut ist immerhin all
terrain punkt liegt hier nicht ich werde
mich laufen gleich schneller raus
brüllen können
im einzigen lauf hat einen punkt so habe
die nächste sache müsste täglich erraten
können glaube ich ich muss zu den
passenden oktober sechs sachen heraus
gesucht oder 56 kolonie
bongo 321 pack eine verkaufen
eine welle wolke tsunami
twitter ja es richtig bitter vogel wird
das richtig ergab das ist nicht dein
ernst
warum kann ich dann überhaupt wo es
könnte nur noch etwas 66 sachen ja gut
ja da kann man richtig verkrüppelt ist
twitter die nachricht aber stimmt schon
da hätte ich auch drauf kommen können
irgendwann mal von der hässlichen
vorgelegt dass ein schoko in blau
schokokugeln mitbieten möchte ich jetzt
auch mal was machen wirklich richtig gut
bauen contractor weg ich respekt an dich
schaut euch jetzt mit einem mono braun
hörten tun
mit dem ausbau es dafür gleich losgehen
wieder kräftig ab über rostock ich habe
mir noch videos losgehen
3 2 1 keinen kaufen kein kaufen
paco er brauche auch keine calvis
presley wahrhafter hat auch was mit geld
zu tun sprach hopp macht spaß macht
selber berichte ich dich selber kein
anderer lacht einfach so so ist das nun
mal
was hat man einen kuchen ein keks ein
burger hamburger cheeseburger takt
bürger täglich mit ketten tun
bad berka keksen brötchen eine
milchschnitte ein keks einfach jedoch an
fünf minuten eine cup gegen brownie big
mac picknick ist richtig nein
doch deswegen unsere brötchen
wo ist das untere brötchen hätte es doch
unten und erwartet ihr sollte dieser
kaka auf
das sieht aus wie fleisch okay ist das
rätsel
der ist richtig gut gelungen und sein
womit ich gearbeitet hätte mit teppichen
und damit den salat und ketchup gemacht
ich habe auch ein teppich aus
übereinander machen geht glaube ich auch
ich weiß es nicht
das tablet schon gibt herausgefunden gab
es erst mal kurz beim abreißen so aus
dass ich mich dadurch kommen wir zu
einem entscheidenden dingen was so alles
entscheiden wir denke ich okay für
brauche ich
drei farben und zwar drei zurzeit vier
farben wie hier ein regenbogen in
verschiedenen farben hole
seid ihr bereit wir haben alles
entscheidende ramos den honig das teil
kriege dann werde ich ja automatisch
erstaunlichen 321 peter vogel was
twitter vogel nein twitter himmel
einfach nein eine wolke die kassa
geraten
eine blaue blumen warte ich noch mal
eine toilette eine telefon mensch winzen
deines nicht wenn sind
gut bereich von radio was google chrome
ja am alter der akademie heute jetzt
automatisch wir haben hier ein stechen
wo sich alles entscheidend wenn ich
einfach mal gerade aufgeholt habe google
chrome ist eine wohltat wenn nicht wenn
es benutzen würde hätte ich vielleicht
auch das logo kennst du doch trotz aber
das hab ich auch schon sowie habe ich
nicht drauf geachtet aber natürlich und
nicht darauf
ich hab ihn nur mozilla rückt jetzt
machen wir ein sprechen und zwar was
mache ich denn jetzt möchte ich
eigentlich noch mal zeit zum überlegen
ich mache jetzt einfach ganz schnell was
soll wir machen hier schere stein papier
könnten wir auch mal ein ach quatsch
nicht so ein müll nicht so meine lieben
freunde 3d bereich alter alter was ist
das für ein roter stein alter zehn
minuten welches tier hin ok meine damen
und herren
komme was ich musste mich mal entleeren
kommt muss katzen ok meine damen und
herren was wir kommen zur alles
entscheidenden runde und zwar von diesem
von dieser runde
okay es geht los
12 eine sau vom hde weinhandl der ebene
bleiben schweinchen simon
das ist eine ewige liebe kriegt ist
direkt raus soll ich mein ja oft bei
verschlechtert abtweiler schweizer mit
und erschwinglich großes verpasst
ich bin hier irgendwo ich bin hier in
der grundkräfte direkt von crafter stehe
ich muss sagen das war es jetzt genau
ist über glückwunsch du hast heute
gewonnen hier beim normalität und mund
da ja genau sprengende ich selber in die
luft
die andern hast aber diana dass die welt
immer geraten
ja leute und vor keiner darf ich mich
nicht enthalten ich springe das war's
mit montagsmaler so eine art bildet die
neue trasse monday enorm an der pier
hängt das nur wieder dabei war
wir haben ja spaß gemacht ich verstehe
ich gar nicht wegen den explosionen die
spanier wieder verursacht unglaublich
und da möchte man meinen leute wenn
solche verein hat wer in der bewertung
klasse sein roter rain und chris zum
nächsten motor und schön mit dir alles
ich will zu gucken und tamtam kamen
du willst aber doch lieber drauf du hast
ja also so finde ich die map eigentlich
viel schöner und jetzt können wir noch
im gange